hence the reason why  the initiation of divorces is so high  amongst women okay i will say though i  think guys go after bad chicks too i  think it's like  i'll clarify this we may have sex with  bad chicks but we're not watching no not  not i  so what i mean is like toxic guys will  act like they're above like going for  the toxic girl but oh come on i've seen  so many guys go after pretty toxic women  yeah and i don't i don't believe for a  second because they'll spend years  dating these girls chasing after these  girls do you know why they're chasing  after them well because they want to get  in the knickers yes  no no but i'm talking no no no pathetic  if you're gonna spend years that's what  i'm saying  i'm just saying that everyone can speak  for yourself  no but i know but  i i swear to god there is a type of guy  that i run into  they like girls that are a little